we have some bad umbrage here and we're
gonna get them out well that's it the
final debate of 2016 is over and
everyone's talking about the same things
we've heard time and again Donald thinks
belittling women makes him bigger why
don't you give back the money that
you've taken from certain countries that
treat certain groups of people so
horribly and Trump supposedly
threatening the very fabric of our
democracy but the loser concedes to the
winner and that the country comes
together in part for the good of the
country
are you saying you're not prepared now
two countries that I will tell you at
the time I'll keep you in suspense well
let me respond to that because that's
horrifying and then in the last 10
minutes of the final debate of the
presidential contest we finally talked
about a little thing called the debt but
the nonpartisan committee for a
responsible federal budget says
Secretary Clinton under your plan debt
would rise to 86 percent of GDP over the
next ten years mr. Trump under your plan
they say would rise to a hundred and
five percent of GDP over the next ten
years Trump wants to cut taxes and raise
spending while denying that it would
explode our debt I say they're wrong
because I'm going to create tremendous
jobs and Clinton wants to raise spending
and raise taxes while denying that would
have any effect on job growth we are
going where the money is we are going to
ask the wealthy and corporations to pay
their fair share and there is no
evidence whatsoever that that will slow
down or diminish our growth in fact I
think just the opposite most economists
accept that high thresholds of
government debt correlates with low
economic growth but you didn't get to
hear that perspective in the debates
brought to you by our wonderful
two-party system this debate is
sponsored by the Commission on
Presidential Debates so while everyone's
talking about rigged elections leaked
emails and puppets
it's pretty clear it's brick remember
that both candidates will run up the
debt oppose free-trade deport more
immigrants and likely mire us and
endless Middle Eastern conflicts happy
voting
[Music]